I am your mother I am your mother you
listen to me Kris Jenner's the ultimate
mom and Meghan Trainor's music video for
mother perhaps the most fitting song
title ever tune in because you never
know what's gonna happen oh we're tuning
in for the visual thermometer trades in
her brunette locks and transforms into a
blonde bombshell going 50s Glam with
Megan by her side
[Music]
it's never a dull moment the ladies both
dance and sing along to the doo-wop
inspired track which samples The
Chordettes 1954 hit Mr Sandman
mother is a recurring theme in Megan's
life the new single comes just months
after revealing she's pregnant with baby
number two
[Applause]
ask for Chris who's mama two six kids
seems she can't resist a good
old-fashioned music video Cameo oh boy
back in 2018 she channeled her mom and
your energy when she starred in Ariana
Grande's thank you next video
this is the first time that I've ever
been in a professional music video with
an iconic artist and someone I admire
very much
[Music]
she is obviously the cool mom yeah right
everybody knows she's the ultimate cool
mom so of course when you're Ariana
Grande you can get you can get just let
anybody to open that DM or if somebody
can answer that call Christian was a pro
she like knows what she's doing yeah she
was Fearless she knew that like this
role was fun and like you can't take
yourself too seriously she got right
into the role so fast she was really
great with improv then there's Chris's
iconic I love my friends video that she
made in 1985 for her 30th birthday
everybody
very happy because the girls are shining
all the time just like another
fun-filled day
I love my friends in 2015 Chris's
daughters Kim Chloe Courtney Kylie and
Kendall recreated it when she turned the
big 6-0 she's learned a lot from all her
good friends
[Music]
I love being someone who's really
present in their lives all the time when
we love being together and hanging out
together and spending every moment
together and you know it sounds
sometimes like too much and now fans
have this gem to remind us of just how
iconic of a mother Chris really is
[Music]
this